Plant cannabinoids like THC and CBD are a special class of compounds derived from cannabis,
which interact with our body's endocannabinoid system.
The network of cellular receptors in the body that helps us maintain homeostasis or
balance.
One key element of the endocannabinoid system are CB1 receptors, which are located mostly
in the brain and nervous system.
These are the receptors that THC activates to produce the high associated with cannabis.
Unlike THC, CBD doesn't fit into CB1 receptors in the same way.
For starters, this makes CBD non-intoxicating, but also gets in the way of compounds like THC,
preventing them from activating CB1 receptors.
This is why CBD can decrease some of THC's major side effects, and why balanced strains containing
both THC and CBD will make you feel very different from THC dominant strains.